chèvres lapins poules chats et chiens
cohabitent ensemble libre au refuge de
la fondation brigitte bardot
depuis 2006 la fondation bénéficie de la
maison de campagne de bébé qu'elle a
achetée dans les années 60
la particularité des trois refuges de la
fondation c'est qu'il n'y a pas de cage
il n'y a pas de cages des animaux sont
pas enfermés ils ont une zone de liberté
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
les chats sont libres de rentrer et
sortir à l'intérieur ils ont tous du
chauffage au sol ils sont libres
brigitte bardot ne voulait pas
initialement avoir des refuges
parce qu'elle avait été très choqué par
les conditions de détention des animaux
dans les associations qui ont des
refuges normaux les animaux sont dans
des cages et s'amuse elle était vraiment
très choqué mais ici ils sont en famille
pour cette première visite au refuge le
chanteur dave engagé dans la cause
animale depuis toujours et venus se
balader sur le terrain de la fondation
contrairement à descartes je pense que
les animaux ont une âme et et qu'il faut
s'en occuper comme si j'étais les êtres
humains et peut-être même mieux parce
que les êtres humains peuvent se
débrouiller comme ils peuvent dire quand
ils sont malades ils peuvent dire quand
ça va pas bien que se plaindre et les
animaux en moi cette possibilité là donc
il faut être très attentif et très
attentionné
le maire de bazoches sur guyonne
dominique nico se félicite de ce refuge
qui apporte une plus-value à sa ville et
un message d'engagement pour la cause
animale
c'est absolument magnifique j'ai connu
la fondation ici à 30 ans ça ne
ressemblait pas évidemment à ça et eu
beaucoup d'investissements qui ont été
faits et c'est absolument extraordinaire
le refuge de la fondation brigitte
bardot ouvrira ses portes tous les
samedis au public pour l'adoption des
chats et pour visiter le parc